[音楽]
おはようございますはじめしゃちょーです
暑くないです
俺だけ
熱くないですかなんか今年の夏いや毎年な
のかもしれませんけど
暑いんですよどうしようもないから太陽見
て
[音楽]
死ぬ日本の夏ってこんな暑かったっけって
ぐらいなんかやけに暑い日々が続いており
ましてもうなんかね外にいることが間違い
なんじゃないかくらい非常にこう危険な
温度が続いております日本ですかくいう私
のこの4億円のお家も非常に
熱いどうしようもないというわけで今日は
この
猛暑日に家に
勇気を降らせたいと思います
シンプルかつ天才私は気づきました
シンプルかつ天才です
暑いのであれば
雪を降らせてしまえばいいんですなぜ安い
かって簡単ですよ
雪が降ってないからです私はじめ社長富山
県出身でして
雪国で育ってるんですよなのでその雪の
冷たさとか寒さとかももう体で体感してて
この夏を打ち消すにはもう雪しかないもう
雪が全てを浄化しますなんか調べたところ
ですねあのー
雪降らせるらしいです
雪降らせるマシンみたいなのが存在する
らしくてそれ今回ちょっとお借りしまして
雪を降らせたいと思います
[音楽]
これが
雪降らせマシーンです見て
すごいこれ大丈夫ギロチンみたいな思っ
てるけどピザあるやつだね
出すんだと思いますなんかかき氷機みたい
な感じが
楽しみです
ちょっと見て全部氷これ見てください
[音楽]
コンビニぐらい涼しいですよこれ結構ね
ひんやり冷気を感じるけどちょっと暑い
からこれ
溶けちゃいますね
ギロチン間違いじゃなかったマジで
ギロチン使ってるちゃんとこれを徐々に
入れていくんですね早速じゃあ作って
もらいましょうよろしくお願いします
来るか行き
雪降るのか
[音楽]
ちょっと待って
雪だ皆さんご覧ください
真夏の
真夏のうちの庭に雪が降ってます
[拍手]
いやすごいよ
[音楽]
めっちゃ雪降ってる
マジでちょっとずつ雪が止まってきてます
うわー降ってきた
こんな感じなんだ
キャッチして
はい取れた
[音楽]
夏だから余計楽しいこれ思ったんですけど
結構ね痛い
落下速度すごいですねこれいやすごい
すごいすごい
雪が徐々に
降り積もっていくと思います
[音楽]
やばい
全面雪になってしまいましたカチカチなの
よもう
氷が
[音楽]
しろはい
積もりました
[音楽]
あのね冷気でこの企画全く熱くないんです
よもうクーラー聞いてるみたいな涼しさ
ですただもうね猛暑で暑すぎて普通に早く
なって雪解けちゃうんでちょっとさすが
飛んでいきましょう
[音楽]
まず足が持ってみたいもん絶対
雪国ならわかるんですけど
雪マジで足突っ込めないんですよ飛び込ん
じゃってみていいですかお願いします行き
ますよ
[音楽]
結構深くまで積もってるのよもう
入りますかすごい
[音楽]
ちょっとね
正直な感想言っていいお願いします
寒い
寒くてちょっと若干
困惑してます
涼しいぐらいかなと思ったらもう寒すぎて
普通にもうやばい表彰するあそこにごめん
なさい雪山も積もってます
[音楽]
かき氷食べますこれもそこら辺食べちゃっ
ていいってこともうどこでもこれ
みんなこれ想像できる8月の出来事だった
綺麗な水使われていると思うので多分
食べれると思います
普通の雪は食えないですかあんまりこう
やってなんかねあんまり体によくね汚い
らしいよ普通の人工の雪ならではので
ちょっとかけますね早速
食べちゃうから
いただきます
[音楽]
何味が一番好きなんですか
メロンここがブルーハワイそしてここにね
穴開いてるからここはじゃあ3つの色を
混ぜて三原色夜遊び
やめられないね
[音楽]
はいというわけでちょっと裏庭が全部雪に
なってしまったんですけれどもこれ実は
管理人に言ってませんそんなことある管理
人の管理下にあるこの裏庭が
雪だらけに出たら代わりに逆算するのか
ちょっと呼んでみたいと思います
前にはじゃない方からぐるっと回って裏来
てほしい
裏の方からグループお願いし
ますはいでは
吹っ飛ばそう
[音楽]
いやすげーこれもやりすぎだねただやっぱ
暑いからすぐ溶けちゃいますね
猛暑だ猛暑
湯気揚がってるとか
[音楽]
はいはいはいはいはいはいはいはいはい
はいはいはいはいはいはい
なんか感じることあります音が聞こえます
ね
温度的にはどうですか
温度
熱い
じゃあちょっと前に冷たい
[音楽]
[拍手]
目開けてください
[音楽]
ちょっと
暑かったので
庭に雪降らせてみました
[音楽]
痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い痛い
[拍手]
はいというわけで家の裏庭に
雪降らせてみたら
夏なのに
寒いことが分かりました
寒いとか冷たかったですねもうよくわかん
ない体の状態になってますただびっくりし
ちゃってます今そして皆さん
夏に雪を降らせる
お値段の方気になりませんか中にこれだけ
の雪を降らせたところ
お値段
[音楽]
100万円